hello and welcome to cloud on air our
live webinars from Google cloud that
happen every Tuesday today we are
talking about the future of databases in
the cloud and my name is Deepti
Shrivastav I am the product manager for
cloud spanner so let's get started so
before we talk about you know spanner
and why we think it's the future of
databases in cloud I think it's
important to go through a little bit of
sort of how we got here right all of us
how how IT and database is in just you
know data itself got here for cloud it
is still very very early so most of
global IT spend as you can see from this
chart that we've you know got from
Gardner here from last year's Gartner
reports basically a very little of it is
still in cloud so each of these
businesses and each of these
infrastructures have a database right UI
you always need to have a database to
store your critical data or not so
critical data so for database spend it's
it's extremely early in terms of cloud
adoption right so as you can see here
first of all most of database spend is
and operational DB's DBMS is and very
little of it is actually in the sort of
non-relational open source world despite
you know all the sort of marketing you
hear from the non-relational side of the
spectrum here they're actually most data
is actually stored in relational
databases and that's sort of obvious
right because with relational databases
you get you know transactions you get
some auto mystery of updates you get
integrity of data you get consistency
guarantees etc which are of course very
very useful as we all know for
developing applications so you know
obviously this
is that a lot of the database database
is out there and our relational and most
of the mission-critical data that is
that a company has will be stored in
relational databases so Before we jump
into sort of the growth of relational
databases you know it's important to
talk about what we mean by
mission-critical right so when we're
talking about mission-critical data what
we really mean is data that is you know
business critical right so loss of that
data or even a glitch in serving that
data affects your your reputation and
has financial risks to your company so
all of this data that is required for
you to run your business is what we call
mission-critical data and we're saying
that you know most of that
mission-critical data is stored in most
cases in relational databases so again
where we at with the current state of
databases right so so most companies as
we talked about earlier right most of
the IT spend is still on Prem what that
means is that most databases are still
running on Prem and most companies are
then managing their own inflexible
database infrastructure on-premises with
you know an army of people trying to
maintain that infrastructure and
maintain their database and keep them
alive and running and you know of course
there's a huge overhead and having those
there are those companies who have you
know taken the leap and adapt adopted
cloud to some extent and what that means
is they're you know using infrastructure
as a service from cloud providers so
they're running their own database
solutions on top of these cloud provided
infrastructure so they're still in the
business of maintaining managing and
administering and keeping their
databases alive they may not need to run
the machines themselves that hosts those
databases but they still have to deal
with the database maintenance and
management and then there are companies
who are have taken a bigger leap where
they're actually paying a service
provider to manage and run their
database solutions in the cloud right so
this means that they don't have to worry
about actually keeping the database
alive
a service that's doing that but that
still means that they they have to make
sure that the databases are running the
way their that's expected and they have
to deal with the service provider for
their database service and maybe deal
with other providers for other services
right so there is some complication
there now apart from where the the
systems and the databases are running
the the other limitation is in
technology itself right so so companies
are Ning into limitations around our
DBMS scale up and scale out and sharding
solutions right so if you run out of
capacity of your database what do you do
right you have to either scale up to
bigger machines or you have to sort of
go to the Charlotte solutions and they
come with their own headaches which
we'll get into in all of it and finally
you know companies are dealing with sort
of the administration and consistency
challenges of scalable solutions that
are also no sequel or non-relational
right so for those companies who already
hit the the problem with their databases
and and the scale of them and have
adopted sort of more scalable solutions
that are no sequel or non relational
right there they're trading off scale
consistency for scale or the traditional
relational semantics for scale they're
running into challenges of sort of
having the consistency issues and the
challenges of running and administrating
these no sequel solutions well they're
on Prem or in the cloud right but the
the technology challenges still remain
so you know what does that mean
for for where we are in terms of the
spectrum of technology so you know we
have this very interesting trade-off
between traditional relational databases
and traditional non relational databases
right so on the business side right
traditional databases provide you with
schema with sequel with consistency and
the no sequel or non-traditional
solutions you know don't provide you
those but they trade those off for high
availability horizontal scalability
replication etc right which is the exact
limitations of traditional relational
databases in most cases what that means
is when you want to run high
availability
relational databases for your
mission-critical applications you have
to create these highly complex
architectures to provide that
availability and replication and
disaster recovery solutions for your
mission-critical data and as you can see
sort of you know you were running
multiple masters you're running read
replicas for you know scaling out and
offloading the the read-only data access
etc you're trying to sort of have men
cash in there somewhere so that you can
do faster reads and writes re reads of
your data which means you have to deal
with the flushing of the cache and you
know you have to deal with consistency
issues with having multiple masters if
you need that you you have backup
replicas so so managing this system now
you've gone from one database that hosts
your mission mission-critical data to
this complicated architecture that you
know again requires an army to maintain
you don't actually know where the
bottlenecks are in some cases right
because the system is so fragile and you
know god forbid if one piece of it can
sort of somehow fails and then you have
to figure out what the cascade effects
are and in most cases you don't actually
even know what the full picture is
because it's become such a complicated
organically-grown beast so so going back
back to first principles great like what
do customers want what do you want from
your database right so obviously you
want it to be highly available and
scalable and you want it to give you
data consistency so you can access data
confidently for your application and you
can serve the correct and accurate data
to your customers right and of course
from from a developer standpoint when
you're building and using these
databases you want simplified operations
right you want standards you want single
points of contact for support you don't
want to have to talk to the database
provider and the infrastructure manager
and the cloud provider separately right
like you want to have one person or one
contact point that you can go to if you
have any issues so you don't have to
deal with
crises by like being the coordinator of
various pieces in that crisis right
basically you want your databases to run
while you can build and grow your
application on your business right and
this is where spanner comes in so why
did we build spanner and how did we get
here right so so if we go back in time
to 2005 you know technical
infrastructure at Google had various
scalable solutions could we've already
reached the skill versus consistency
problem right so we had scalable data
storage systems but we were lacking in
transactions and relational semantics in
those systems and as we've learned right
as we all know those relational
semantics sequel etc are very important
and they really help you run your
business well so you know Google reach
that point and so the need of the hour
was horizontally scaling databases brief
asset transactions and global
consistency and of course we are Google
so we want no downtime right we want
high availability we want you to be able
to access Google from anywhere at all
times so we came up with spanner we
developed spanner with a lot of research
and a lot of understanding of how to
build distributed scalable highly
available systems and what we have here
is basically the paper that we published
in 2012 that talks about the technology
that we built at the time so spanner was
launched externally as cloud spanner
which is a publicly available product on
Google cloud platform and it's about
exactly a year ago that it was launched
publicly on GCP so we're celebrating our
first anniversary as a as a cloud
database so cloud spanner is basically
an enterprise-grade globally distributed
and strongly consistent database service
built specifically for the cloud to
combine the benefits of our relational
database
structure with non-relational horizontal
scale so what does that mean
right we're basically saying you don't
have to trade off or make compromises
between relational semantics and
horizontal scale which is what
traditionally companies and you know I
team folks have had to do right database
users have had to do they've had to
basically trade off and give up on
relational semantics and build that in
the application to get horizontal scale
to manage their data growth over the
course of you know the data exploding it
for their business right so spanner
allows you to not have to make that
compromise it's are no compromise
relational database service right and
you get all of this packaged up in a
managed service so you can focus on your
database and not have to worry about
running so you can focus on the
application using that database and not
have to worry about you know running the
database itself so we provide you know
schemas as a transaction sequel and the
relational scale with up to five nines
of availability and an availability SLA
so we guarantee that we in a fully
managed easily scalable service so if we
are back to our chart of you know what
are the pros and cons of relational
versus traditional non-relational
services or databases right basically
you don't have to make those trade-offs
right we have schemas we have sequel we
have consistency like traditional
relational databases and we have
availability scale and replication and
by the way a bunch of it is out of the
box that you can get with non trip so
tradition non-relational traditional
sort of no sequel systems so again right
you don't have to make compromises
between technical needs and business
needs in order to really run your
applications in your and your business
critical data now there are differences
right in in the technology of spanner
and you know traditional relational
databases now they've worked you know so
far
and of course you know there is
innovation here that allows us to do
this this relational with scale and I
can touch upon a little bit of that but
the important thing to note here is you
know like traditional databases do you
get tables you get DDL you get you know
the same sort of schemas that you're
used to so you do create table you you
know you have primary keys etc right and
in this picture you can see that you
know we've created two different tables
you know which are have relationships
that you can see and you use simple DDL
statements in order to create this table
and you know you'll use sort of this
sort of schema change DDL statements as
well to alter table or drop column etc
as well so again these are the familiar
constructs that you're used to so far
with the traditional relational that you
get with spanner as well with some added
benefits right so in this case you see
these two tables and if we were to see
how this logical structures laid out
spanner has a concept of interleaving
it's one of the many technical
differences but it's interesting to
point out as it kind of showcases how
you know we've been built for scale with
the relational term transactional
semantics so in the previous case we had
two different tables and they're
logically different right there's the
albums table and the singers table but
if you interleave the albums table in
the singers table what that means is
that the data is logically co-located
right so you essentially can think of it
as a pre joint so when you're doing
large data set reads or scans you don't
have to actually do the join at a
runtime right you can predetermine that
these data sets are going to be sort of
query together and you can logically
tell the system to store them together
so that they can be retrieved much
faster now you know for for a few Meg's
or a few gigs of data right like joining
may not be a latency causing issue but
when you have hundreds of gigabytes or
hundreds of terabytes of data and you
need to do all albums and all for all
singers sort of a choir
that's a lot of data to be joined and
processed at runtime at query time so
instead of having to do a join at that
time you can specify to the system that
you need to pre join this data set
because your most common queries are
actually going to scan the Stingers
along with their albums right so in this
case the system can very quickly you
know basically read the data and return
the query result without having to do
the the computationally intensive joint
hence reducing read time write a query
serving time again you can use
interleaving for indexes as well so you
know we have secondary indexes we are
relational database and from that
standpoint you know you can of course
have you know separate logical indexes
which can be you know standard tables in
in other traditional databases right and
in our case they are standard tables as
well but you can interleave them right
so again if you're going to have two
back join indexes with the base table
because you of your most common queries
requiring that pattern then you can
interleave the indexes within the base
table and again that can lead to much
faster selects than queries of your data
so this is just one of the ways in which
spanner is different but it sort of
shows you under the covers like you know
the the technological differences we
have which allows us to provide scale
with relational semantics so you know as
Nick says in this you know quote from
Gartner so when we talked about you know
when we launched spanner and we talked
about it with various analysts and you
know of course we have customers are
using it it's interesting because you
know it's not just another take on a
traditional database right it's really a
new way of thinking and you need that's
being met by the technology that's
banner but spanner is not just software
right it's it's the combination of a lot
of very clever software which there is a
lot of along with hardware that we've
built specifically
for you know scale and to provide the
kinds of things that we need for a large
highly available scalable system such as
atomic clocks that you know we have in
in house like true time is a technology
we use for global synchronization and
external consistency right which is
stronger than linearize ability so we
use true time which is based on atomic
clocks and GPS to do this coordination
and that powers sort of cloud spanner as
well and allows it to have that global
external consistency which allows us
that then have globally consistent and
strong you know strong relational
semantics database in cloud spanner and
this is of course build on top of our
Google Network which you know we've
we've talked about quite a bunch and
there's a lot of you know white papers
that we've actually put online as well
that you know one can read if interested
but basically if the combination of our
Google networking which is you know
highly redundant and optimized on all
levels right from the network fabric all
the way to the to the switches to the
you know to the hubs etc and atomic
clocks and GPS with true time as well as
clever software in clouds banner itself
so you know we for example have wrote
our own implementation of Paxos we don't
use the open source Paxos implementation
we optimize the taxes algorithm in our
implementation for our specific use case
which allows us to again do low latency
transactions and to do strong reads
across continents and across oceanic
links and all of this kind of combines
to give you clouds banner so there's a
bunch of you know customers that are
using spanner and they're excited about
it and you know I am personally excited
to talk about you know a few of them
that I've been in sort of seeing them
win and it's really exciting for us to
see how the world has adopted and
started to use spanner right so it's not
just about you know trading off capex
for our backs
which is what a managed database service
gives you that's kind of the promise of
cloud but with cloud customers are
trying to do inherently new and exciting
things that they couldn't do before
because they were limited by technology
and in this case you know opt IVA which
is a telecom communications billing and
charging system so you know as
mission-critical as they get it has
basically adopted spanner as its next
generation database system for its next
generation sort of software - for
billing and charging right and you know
when they looked at spanner they saw you
know improved performance and
reliability from the existing
traditional architectures and they
actually saw ten times more throughput
so 10 times more transactions per second
at a dramatically reduced cost so ops
you is actually presenting this week at
Mobile World Congress in Barcelona and
I'm here with you and I'm not there but
it's really exciting because you know
they're they're really excited about the
technology right they're really excited
about the possibilities it opens up for
them and for their customers right and
that's really the reason to have sort of
cloud spanners and managed database
service right they don't have to worry
about the system itself and also because
of its combination of relational
semantics and horizontal scale they can
do things with this technology that they
couldn't do with their existing on-prem
solutions so another interesting example
one of my favorites actually Marketo and
the one following is again you know
Marketo is a marketing platform that you
know provides marketing applications for
companies all over the world right and
for them you know in their own words
right having order sequence in our
application logic is very in their
application logic is very important and
as they were looking to go to cloud and
looking obviously you know the first
step is you know which cloud provider do
I use in the second question for most of
us is well what database services do
each of these cloud providers have right
and and how do do I use them right
is it easier for me to use these
services or is it going to make my life
more difficult and MacLeod spanner
basically again they could use the
system to have the kind of order and
sequence guarantees in the app logic so
they didn't have to write brittle
application logic to have that
sequencing right with no sequel and with
sort of systems that are skilled but but
lacking in transactional consistency or
strong consistency all of that has to be
built into the app right which means
your application becomes a lot more
complicated and your team is basically
stressing in keeping that system alive
and running instead of you know building
cool things to serve your your customers
and you know that obviously is a
productivity hit but also a growth hit
for you right it's a it affects your
business bottom line and in this case
when you don't have to worry about that
anymore you know you can choose spanner
you don't have to reap lat for more
think of real platforming ever you just
grow as your global business grows I
mean that's a powerful statement right
and you know another one of our favorite
customers Evernote you know I think a
lot of people know Evernote again they
had a multiple hundred shard in my
sequel system you know they want their
users notes to be obviously available no
matter where they are and you know they
with cloud spanner can go to a system
that reduces this complexity gives them
scale and once they have migrated they
don't actually have to think about three
platform you know again ever again right
so it reduces in fact eliminates all of
that stress of sort of managing the
complicated multi shard my sequel system
that keeps you know their operations
team sort of awake at night from from
that to sort of building more
functionality and having ease of use of
their their application and
infrastructure so you know we talked
about through the
the positive things in cloud spanner or
you know how it's different from
traditional relational and
non-relational databases but it's
important to note that Google cloud
platforms database portfolio is vast
right and spanner is one piece of it
right we actually have you know memcache
all the way on the left to you know our
sort of data warehouse in the cloud with
bigquery right so the way I think about
cloud spanner and bigquery is you know
if you're used to sort of you know
traditional relational databases you
know and data warehouses right
clouds banner and cloud bigquery are
sort of the cloud equivalents of those
right but you know it's deliberately
placed next to cloud Spanos deliberately
placed next to non relational systems in
this chart because you know it allows
you to have non-relational scale right
along with the relational semantics that
it offers so you know the whole
portfolio basically allows you to have a
bunch of tools that you can choose from
to build the kinds of systems you need
right for your application right we're
not trying to tie you down to one and
only one solution but we're not giving
you hundreds to choose from right we
think there are different use cases that
require very specific tailored solutions
for storage and you know with this
portfolio we basically offer you a
solution for each of those specific use
cases what that also means is again you
have the toolkit to choose the right
system but you're not left on your own
to figure out sort of rich system you
need to use among hundreds right or or
dozens right there's as I said a
solution for each specific use case and
we help you choose the right system for
the use case so as this chart search
shows you know there's basically a flow
chart that you can use to pick the
system you want for the use case you
have and this is again up on our docks
in cloud.google.com so you can look it
up there as well along with a lot more
information
so hopefully that kind of gave you an
overview of why we
think to clouds banners a future of
database systems and we'll take a short
break of less than a minute and come
back for a live Q&A section as well so
stay tuned
you
welcome back to cloud on air let's get
straight into our audience questions for
the day from this webinar so question
one
are you expecting all relational
databases to migrate to cloud
immediately absolutely not right like
there are many reasons why sort of most
of the clouds band is still sorry most
of the IT spend is still in on Prem and
not in the cloud right as I had
mentioned earlier in my talk so if we
know that these are early days cloud but
what we want to make sure that customers
understand that they don't need to shy
away from adopting cloud because they
think they can't get the performance or
the semantics that they're expecting
from their applications in the cloud
right and you know if you're needing
horizontal scale and relational
semantics for example you know you don't
have to sort of worry about not being
able to do that in the cloud because you
know for example we have cloud span
around on Google cloud that will allow
you to have that without compromises so
we expect you know most of the cloud
migration to have in the next five ish
years three to five years and beyond
right there are many reasons for not
being in the cloud right now as I said
you know you you've already made
commitments you've already bought the
machines you've already got data spent
Center space you've already got color
space for your data infrastructure so
you know it will take time but I know
that you know a lot of companies are
looking at migrating to the cloud and
it's important that they see the full
picture and all the options available to
them so that they don't have to shy away
from it for let's say performance or
manageability or any of those reasons so
moving on
why not just use a non relational
database on Prem or in the cloud right
so I think I touched upon that earlier
um you know if you want to use a non
relational database that's totally up to
you
however should non-relational databases
come with the complexity that we talked
about right you know if you need
relational semantics and and most
mission-critical data does right like
bank systems telco systems health care
systems right
when you need relational semantics and
you're trying to use a non relational
database what that means is you've given
up on transaction of the system you've
given up on strong consistency you've
given up on structured data you've given
up on sequel sequel like is not the same
as sequel right anybody who's used a
sequel Lite system can know that it's
not sequel so you've given up on all of
those to get the scale with these
non-relational databases and if that
works for you great but but it does mean
that if you need those things you have
to build them in the application and
anybody who's even attempted to build
them knows that this is super
complicated code it's got so many sort
of edge cases that you have to you know
sort of think about and take care of
it's brittle because you know actually
building rolling your own transactions
and the application layer is hard
coordinate in the in the shard solution
for example right doing the logic to
join between two shards and you know all
those kinds of things are really hard
and again if you like doing that kind of
stuff that's great but for most people
they're trying to just you know build
their applications run their businesses
right and they don't want to worry about
these things in that case you know
non-relational databases just don't cut
it right for what they need okay what's
the difference between cloud spanner in
bigquery can't I just use bigquery um so
it's basically the difference between
all T P systems and OLAP systems right
so are you looking for an enterprise
data warehouse or are you looking for a
operational mission critical database
right that is literally when you would
choose one or the other cloud spanner
for royalty P systems and you know
bigquery for OLAP systems so or
enterprise data warehouse so you know if
I were to think about it in in Indy
on-prem world or in the traditional
world you know it would be the
difference between Oracle or sequel
server and net teaser or teradata right
that's that's the real difference and in
fact we're basically trying to make it
simple for customers to use their
operational data in a data warehouse
with you know cloud span or bigquery so
you can you don't have to like have
complicated tools for
et yelling data out of your relational
database out of your operational
database and and moving into your data
warehouse right like there are simple
tools that we are working on that will
just basically allow you to quickly
transfer data from cloud spanner into
bigquery and then over time that you
don't even have to do the detail at all
it can be as simple as a push-button
thing moving on this cloud spanner have
every feature that traditional databases
do know right it's a different take on
the system so there are specific sort of
features that cloud spanner doesn't have
now that we're working on to fill those
gaps like you know DML obviously and
backups and sort of things like that and
and triggers and queues these are all
part of our roadmap right so so you I
would hope that our audience and our
customers give us you know some time
because you know we just launched last
year and you know traditional databases
have been around for you know 30 40
years so we're trying and moving very
fast and you know we've got a closer
than two sorry those relational database
feature gaps that are critical right
there are certain things that are not
critical for relational databases that
are somehow are supposed to be you know
stored procedures for example right
that's just a way of pushing down
application logic into sort of the
database layer which you know we don't
actually think that's there the way we
want to go right with our system you
know we want to have a lean mean
database that can sort of do the things
you need it to do which is you know
strong consistency application
traditional
sorry transactions etc and we want to
give this to you in global scale right
but we we think that application
developers know best how to write their
applications and and you know that's the
way we kind of want to offer this
service so we wave cloud spanner with a
new take on databases we were able to
sort of you know go back to first
principles and think about why databases
exist and what they're needed for what
they're used for right and we were able
to cut out all the sort of flack that
has cruft that's been building up in
databases for a while and we were able
to go back to first principles
and then provide you know the features
and functionality that you know are
truly core for databases especially
relational databases you know and as I
said yes it doesn't have every feature
right now which we're gonna fill but it
also has features that no other
relational database or in fact no other
database has right which is global
strong consistency you replication
out-of-the-box and you know transparent
securities again built in in transparent
etc next question why is charting a
database so difficult um so you it's if
you ever sort of had to char the
database you know this would be sort of
an obvious question or obvious answer
really so so think about a database with
a bunch of tables right and now think
about the fact that you can't actually
buy a big enough box to hold all that
data in all those tables so what do you
have to do then is and I'm gonna
simplify here there are many things that
go into consideration here but at the
simplest level what you have to do is
basically take the table if you have ten
tables take each table and then put it
on a different database right because
that way at least the data set for that
table is going to fit in your
traditional you know single box machine
so you have ten tables across ten
different databases so you you know it's
of course you can just keep using your
tooling and you can keep using
transactions all for within that table
or maybe two tables right with the table
and an index let's say right but it
behaves exactly the same as one database
for that one table and it's one index
right but if you ever have to do
anything across those tables then you
have to write the transaction logic in
the application to do the join and to do
the transactions on them right so you
essentially will have to write the
protocol to commit a transaction that is
done in a database inside the
application layer without having the
sort of engine that runs the system
right the database engine is what runs
these transactions etc and does the
consistency and guarantees etc so to do
that in the application layer is
extremely hard and as I said very
brittle right
because what happens when you know one
if you if you're doing a two-phase
commit for example what happens if one
shard is unavailable but the other shard
committed so do you roll back that short
order you retry on the on the first stop
a shard right and what happens if you
know during the commit there was a
network outage right so do you know
whether the transaction committed or not
right like how do you recover from that
state etc right so there's many many
things that go into making a Charlotte
databases sorry shard database work well
and all of them basically make the
application developers live very hard so
those are some of the questions we had I
don't think we have any more questions
so I think we'll call it a day and thank
you again for watching and for tuning in
to our live webinar as I said we have
these live webinars for cloud on there
every Tuesday so please log in next
Tuesday for our upcoming webinars on
collaboration and productivity tools as
well as machine learning among other
topics thank you so much have a great
day